OWEN: Welcome.
I'd like to welcome to
Google Ralph Simpson.
Ralph is a 30-plus year
veteran of technology industry,
recently retired.
He volunteers at
History San Jose
and is an avid collector
of cipher machines,
has probably a couple
dozen cipher machines
in his collection.
And he's agreed
to come here today
to tell us about
his Enigma machine.
And he's going to be demoing it
and also letting people come up
and play it with
afterwards, I guess.
RALPH SIMPSON: Sure.
OWEN: And so welcome, Ralph.
[APPLAUSE]
RALPH SIMPSON: Thank
you very much, Owen.
It's a real pleasure and an
honor for me to be here today.
I really appreciate the time
that you are providing here
for me.
To be able to speak at a Google
Tech Talk is quite an honor.
And I really look forward to it.
This little machine here is not
only of great interest to me,
I think it also reflects
a huge historical value,
both in terms of what it
meant in World War II,
as well as what it
led to afterwards,
because in breaking the
code during World War II,
basically the Allies had to
come up with modern computing.
And you could argue that the
computer revolution, Silicon
Valley, and even Google
here has its roots back
to this little humble
typewriter in a wooden box.
And so what I'd
like to do today is
go through that early history,
the technology of the machine,
and, let's see--
the early history,
the technology the machine.
I'll do a demonstration
as Owen mentioned.
And then I want to talk about
the significance of this
to World War II and how the
Allies actually broke the code
and how that led to
modern computing.
Now there's at the
end a calculation
of the key length
of the Enigma, which
I will not have
time to go through.
But it's there.
It doesn't take a lot of math.
And it is enlightening,
so I'd encourage
you to use that as an
exercise with a reader.
It's really quite interesting.
So if you take a look at what
drove the need for something
like an Enigma
machine, it actually
started in World War I because
of the proliferation of radios
for the first time in warfare.
And that was a huge advantage.
But after the war,
the Germans were
horrified to find out
that all of their messages
were being read.
And it wasn't just the Germans.
Every single message
was being read.
And part of the
reason is that if you
look at the types of cipher
devices that were available,
they were really made for
a different environment.
They were made in order to send
a message, a written message,
by courier or in some
other fashion where
it wasn't on a radio.
As soon as you're talking about
having hundreds or thousands
of messages on a radio
with the same code,
that can easily be broken.
Letter frequency
analysis, you identify
which letters are the most
frequent in the first letter
of each message, the second
letter, the third letter.
And generally you
can break these codes
in minutes, not hours.
And I brought a few examples.
You see on the left here,
it's called a Vigenere wheel.
This one was used by
the Confederate Army.
It was invented in
the 1400s, so this
has been around a long time.
Here is a life-size
replica of that wheel.
There's only five in existence,
so I had to get a replica.
But it's a very simple device.
You can see there's the
alphabet in two wheels here.
You just use a code
word and spin this
and come up with a new
algorithm for each code word.
Unfortunately, this
is easily broken.
And in fact, the North broke
the Confederate Vigenere wheel
regularly.
I mean, it was-- the South only
used three different code words
all during the war,
so it was quite easy
for them to break it.
And that's despite the fact that
"Scientific American" magazine
in 1917 said this
device was unbreakable.
Shows you what they know.
Here's another example.
Now, this one came out
just after World War I.
But it was used by the Army
up through World War II.
This was invented by
the US Army in 1922.
And you can see each of these
are separate wheels that
have the alphabet in a
different configuration
around the outside.
And the way it's
used is you just
write your message in
25 lines across this.
And then you spin this wheel
around and pick any other line
to send as your gibberish.
And then the receiver
would print out
that gibberish and then would
have to search around the wheel
to see something that looks
like normal English or German
or whatever your language is.
But it was also
found in 1922, just
by coincidence in Thomas
Jefferson's papers,
that actually he invented this.
I'm talking about
our second president.
He invented this device.
And his had 36
wheels instead of 25.
But he described it exactly.
And they actually
have an example of it
at the NSA Museum in
Fort Meade, Maryland,
where you can take a look at it.
By the way, if you
have any questions,
feel free to ask me
as I go through this.
Another thing I
wanted to show you,
I talked about this Vigenere
wheel and it's from the 1400s.
That doesn't mean
that it ended there.
Here is a US version
of that Vigenere wheel
that was used in
the Vietnam War.
Vietnam.
And what you do is you take
this little thing down.
You attach a little
cassette tape to it.
And then the cassette tape,
by spinning this around,
will put a different
Morse code on the tape.
You can take this off and
then connect it to a radio.
And it would send it in a
blast mode very quickly.
But it's using the
Vigenere wheel.
Now you may ask,
why in the world
would we use this in Vietnam
when obviously there's
much better technologies,
this one can be broken?
Well, in battlefield
conditions, this is very fast.
It's easy to do.
And if you only need to confuse
the enemy for an hour or two,
this works.
If it's more than
that, it's not good.
Now I wanted to show you
one other, or a couple more.
Another one is a simple book.
This is a code book from 1988.
It's called "Commercial
Cryptograph."
There were military versions
of these types of code books.
But it has words
and phrases written
on one side, other words and
numbers written on the other.
And so you all you have to do
is just make up your message,
look up the words, and send
other words or other numbers.
And that's how you send a code.
This has also been in
use since the 1400s.
And this is
relatively effective.
The problem is, as soon as
it's broken by losing a book,
you're dead in the water.
And to then send out books to
thousands of army locations
is just untenable.
So it was typically used
more for diplomatic locations
and high commands
and things like that.
And the last one I'll show
you is another US Army one,
just to show you what was used
by the US Army in World War II
to compare it to
the Enigma machine.
The Enigma machine
is a 26-pound device.
It's a typewriter.
You press on a key,
a light lights up.
Somebody has to write it down.
That somebody is usually
a second operator,
so that they can go fast.
This device is a little
bit different than that.
You can see there
are six wheels.
It uses a whole
different technology.
There is no battery,
no electricity.
And actually it performs an XOR
exclusive or operation in this.
And then it prints
out the results.
And it can cipher and decipher
just with the switch of a key
here.
So it's very handy,
smaller, easier to carry.
No batteries needed.
But not as effective, and
not as cryptologically strong
as the Enigma machine.
So this one was used, again,
as a battlefield cipher.
It was typically broken by the
Germans in a couple of hours.
OK.
So let me go on.
What I wanted to show you was
kind of the background of what
environment was in place
when the Enigma machine was
invented, and why there was
a need for something that
was stronger, that
could work better
than what was in
existence at the time.
And it turns out that
the Enigma machine
wasn't the only
rotor-based cipher machine.
Now, what was unique
about the Enigma
machine and these other
rotor-based cipher
machines is the rotor itself.
This is the Enigma rotor.
And as you can see, it has
these little pin connectors.
There's 26 of them,
representing all the letters
of the alphabet.
On the other side
is the connectors.
And what it has
in the middle are
wires that will connect one
letter to a different letter.
So an A may be connected
to a G in this rotor,
but the A may be connected
to a B in one of the others.
They're all wired differently.
And so this is the
key innovation,
which maybe doesn't
sound all that great.
But at the time this was huge,
because when you put three
in a row, that means that the
letter is changed three times.
And actually in the Enigma,
there's a reflector.
So it goes through.
And then it goes
through a reflector.
It's changed again and then
gets changed three more times.
So this was quite an effective
way to encipher messages.
The other thing was that
it made it very easy.
If you notice on
some of the others,
it's a very manual
process, error-prone, a lot
of fiddling around.
Here, you just type
on a typewriter.
Much less room for error.
So that was the innovation.
Now, it turns out that the
Enigma wasn't the only one that
was invented in this
same time frame.
Like I said, World
War I showed the need.
And so this was invented
around the world.
There are four
different countries,
four different inventors
all within a few years
came up with this
same rotor concept.
And the first inventor was
here in the US, Edward Hebern.
He was actually in jail for
stealing a horse in 1915.
And he said he came up with
the idea while he was in jail.
And when he got out, he came
up with a really nifty-looking
device.
He didn't make a lot
of those, although he
did get a million dollars
worth of investment money.
He built a huge manufacturing
plant in Oakland
that was going to
house 1,500 workers.
And after making a
couple of dozen machines,
he went bankrupt.
And then he got thrown in jail
again for stock manipulation,
so that one went by the wayside.
Then we have the Enigma machine.
Now, that Enigma
machine you can see
is different than the one
that's sitting before you.
That was the first version.
It weighed 110 pounds.
And not a lot of those sold.
It was very cumbersome to use.
And then by the mid
'20s, he came up
with this version, which
is a 26-pound device.
And it got accepted by
the German military.
Hugo Koch in Holland
came up with a design.
He actually developed some
prototypes in the lab.
But they didn't work very
well, so he never really
was able to sell
these commercially.
And Arvid Damm is
an interesting guy.
He came up with a
device and sold some.
And in fact, the guy that bought
him out was named Hagelin.
Hagelin formed a company
called Crypto AG.
And the first big sale he had
was this device right here.
He sold 140,000 of these
to the US government,
which allowed him
then after the War
to sell these around the world,
or a follow-on version of that.
And he ended up selling
to 130 countries,
their military, diplomats.
It was used everywhere.
What wasn't known
was that the NSA
had a sweetheart deal with
them and had a back door.
So this story of the NSA
goes way back, right?
This is from the '50s.
And that back door
existed for about 40 years
before it was unearthed
by Iran in 1999.
So there's a whole history here.
I could do a whole nother
Tech Talk on Hagelin.
But I have to go on.
And as you can see on
the next slide, what
I want to talk about now
is the Enigma machine.
Now, the Enigma was
invented, as you can see,
by Arthur Scherbius. w And Hugo
Koch was the other inventor
that I said never
got off the ground.
His device was too intermittent
and didn't work well.
But in 1927, Scherbius
did a strange thing.
He bought the rights
to Koch's patent.
Now, the reason I
say that's strange
is Scherbius had
the earlier patent.
And it turns out they
were identical patents.
So why would he buy this right?
It was never really understood.
It was kind of a
mystery, until 2003.
So here again in the story
of ciphering, a lot of times
we find things out after the
fact, sometimes decades or even
hundreds of years
after the fact.
And here what we found out was
that the rotor-based cipher
machine was not invented
by these four gentleman
that I showed you earlier.
We have to rewrite history.
It was actually invented by
two Dutch Naval officers.
They built a machine in 1915.
And that machine worked.
They showed it to
the Dutch Navy.
And this was at
World War I time.
They decided to squelch it.
And they would not
allow these two Naval
officers to patent that device.
And it just so happens
that the patent attorney
that these Dutch
Naval officers hired
was the brother-in-law
of Hugo Koch.
What a coincidence.
And it turns out also
that Hugo Koch and Arthur
Scherbius were collaborators.
So they worked together
in stealing the patent
and coming up with the Enigma.
And I think that Scherbius
felt a little bit
like he owed
something to Hugo Koch
and gave him a little bit of
money to buy out his patent.
So that's the story
behind Hugo Koch.
So after all of this
and all the stories
you're going to read
about Hugo Koch,
it turns out it's
these two Dutch Naval
officers that invented
the Enigma machine.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
idea who the two Dutch Naval
officers are?
RALPH SIMPSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
The question is, who are the
two Dutch Naval officers?
I don't know a lot about them.
I do know their names.
It's Theo van Hengel.
And the other one
is RPC Stengler.
Those are the two
Dutch Naval officers.
There's not a lot of
information about them.
But they were the
ones that invented it.
They were tasked to invent it,
basically, by the Dutch Navy.
And when they did,
the Dutch Navy
didn't want it out
for some reason.
It's also interesting
that they happened
to release that
requirement that they not
publish this or
get a patent on it.
But Hugo Koch came
out with his patent
just two weeks
before that release.
And so it was too late.
So here is a picture of it.
And you can see it
in front of you here.
This is a typewriter
type device.
The innovation is these rotors
that messes up the alphabet.
And the other thing
that I should mention
is that the way
this works is when
you press a key-- and
this key does two things.
It advances the rotors
mechanically, not electrically.
And it sets up an
electrical signal
that goes through
first the plug board--
and I'll discuss each of these
pieces more in just a minute.
But it first goes
through the plug board.
Then it goes through
each of the three rotors.
It goes through a
reflector, reflecting back
through the three rotors,
back to the plug board.
And then it lights up a light.
So it does create quite
a different algorithm,
because that rotor will advance
every time you push a key.
And it advances odometer style,
with the right one advancing
once each time you press, the
next one advancing every 26
times, and so forth.
So that's the way
this thing works.
I'll go through
each of the pieces
here, just so you have a good
sense for what this is all
about.
I really like the way that
they put this together.
It's 26 pounds.
It's very heavy.
But this thing is definite
German engineering.
It's heavy duty, very well made.
You can see the keys are
made of stainless steel.
This is over a
70-year-old device.
I've done nothing to it.
And it works right
out of the box.
And I haven't had
to do anything to it
other than put a little
bit of oil on it.
And it works to this day.
And you can tell it's very
strongly made, because it does
have to advance some
pretty heavy rotors.
So in other words, you
can't touch-type on this.
You have to push down
one letter at a time.
And it takes a bit of effort.
The other thing I
should mention is,
you'll notice that
there's only 26 keys.
There's no special characters,
no numbers, anything else,
no space bar.
So they don't allow that
in the cipher message.
You have to write
out the numbers.
They did allow an X
for a sentence stop.
And basically, they ran
all the words together,
because you don't
want to give hints
on where the spaces or the
spacing of words could be.
So that's the way that works.
If you go to the next
element here-- so
I'm going to go through the way
that the electrical signal will
go.
So next is the plug board.
Now, as you can
see, the plug board
is in the same format
as the typewriter keys.
And the bulbs will be
in the same format.
It's a QWERTZ format,
not a QWERTY format.
And basically what this does
is you attach one letter
to another.
So if you were to
press-- for instance,
here you can see
that I've got a Q
and it's attached to something.
Let's call it the O. So
if you press a Q here,
it's going to
transfer that to an O
before it goes to the rotors.
OK?
That's all it does.
And coming back, if
it comes back as an O,
it'll change it to a
Q. That's all it does.
This was something that
Scherbius did not design.
So Scherbius designed all of
this sans this plug board.
And it turns out that the plug
board added more cryptological
strength than all the rest of
the machine combined, which
is very interesting.
So the military added that.
And they only used
it for the military.
They continued to sell a
commercial version of this
to other countries that did
not include the plug board.
OK.
And here is a picture
of the rotors.
And I think I showed
you these already.
One thing I don't
think I mentioned
was there's a little notch here.
This notch can be moved to
any of the 26 characters.
And what that notch does is,
when it's in the machine,
it sets the point for when
the next rotor to the left
will advance.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I noticed that
not all the plug board
connections had connections.
What happens when you don't
have the letter connected?
RALPH SIMPSON: Yeah.
When it's not connected,
it basically bypasses.
Oh.
The question is that
not all the plug board
connections had a cable in it.
And that was done on purpose.
And so if a letter was not
plugged, let's say a B,
the B just went straight
through without any change.
OK.
And so this is the rotors.
You can see a couple
of facts about these.
I have three of them here.
But in a general Army
Enigma situation,
they would have
five to select from.
And each day they would
have to change them.
And therefore, you can have five
in one position, any of five,
four, three, 60 different
combinations of rotors in this.
You can also set this
on any of 26 letters.
And there's three of them.
So it's 26 cubed.
And the notch can be set
on any of 26 positions.
But only the right
two rotors matter.
The left rotor isn't
going to move anything.
So that gives you a sense
for the key strength
of just the rotors.
It's actually not a big number.
In the Naval version of the
Enigma, they had four rotors.
So that gave them
a little bit more.
And they also could select
from eight, instead of five,
so that also gave them
a greater strength.
Next that I want to talk
about is the reflector itself.
The reflector is this
item here that you
see with the big
red B on it, just
to the left of the three rotors.
And what that does is
it takes the signal
from the leftmost rotor and it
swaps it for another letter.
And so it works much
like the plug board,
but with all the
letters plugged.
So if for instance
you come in as an A
and it was enciphered to a G,
if you came in to this reflector
with a G, it would come
out enciphered as an A.
And the reason for
that is this allows
you to encipher and decipher
with the same code settings.
Very handy.
Ease of use was all-important
on a battlefield,
so this made it very easy.
Also, this became
a very big home
in the design of the
Enigma, because what
it meant was no letter
could encipher to itself.
And so keep that in mind
as I go through this,
because that was a big hole.
But I think the
Germans felt that this
was important to be able
to encipher and decipher
without having to change
keys or change settings.
And so they left it that way.
All right.
So the last section I
wanted to show you on this
is the lamp board.
The lamp board actually
has a small little light
underneath each of the
letters, so when you press down
on a key, a light lights up.
It seems very simple.
But it goes through this
tremendous calculation
of changing letters.
And the other thing
I should mention
is that there is
a battery in this.
It's a square, fairly large 4
1/2 volt battery that was used
in World War II.
I've replaced it with
two AA batteries,
which is only 3 volts.
But it seems to work fine.
And also you can attach
this to a 220 volt
plug, which was a
European power supply.
And so it works-- with
just a flip of the switch
you can attach it to that.
Or you can attach it to a
transformer they also had.
So there was multiple
ways to do this.
Within the lid here, you see
a couple of other things.
There are some spare plug
cables for the plug board.
There are some
spare light bulbs,
in case you have a
burned-out light.
Interestingly, I've had this
machine for about 12 years.
And I've never had a
light burn out yet.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RALPH SIMPSON: To test what?
AUDIENCE: To test
all the lights.
RALPH SIMPSON: Yes.
Yes.
That's a good question.
So the question is, is there
a way to the test lights,
rather than just trying
it, because how do you
know if the light's out, right?
Well, they thought of
that, believe it or not.
So if you look
inside here, there's
a little empty plug here
that's written in German.
But it's basically a test plug.
You just put the light in there.
And if it lights up it works.
If it doesn't, it's dead
and you throw it away.
And so they thought
of those things too.
OK.
Oh, and also I have in
here a little light filter.
It's really just
a tinted plastic.
And what this is used for is
when you're in direct sunlight,
it's sometimes hard to
see the light light up.
And so when you put this in
here and cover the lights,
it actually shows up
a little bit better.
And you can read these.
Now, I'm going to leave this
in place, because when we film,
it turns out you can see
the letters light up better
even on video this way.
And then here is a
description of how
to take care of the machine.
It tells you about
how to oil it,
how to sand the
little rotor fingers,
and what you need to do
to keep it operational.
So here's the wiring diagram.
I've already really gone
through all of this.
But this will just
show you an example
if you hit the H key
what it goes through.
And each of these
numbers represents
a change of characters.
So if you hit the H
key and the H cable
is plugged over to the O,
as you see, it changes.
That's the first
change of letters.
And then it goes through
the three rotors,
where it's changed.
It goes through the reflector,
back through the three rotors,
and back through the plug board.
So it could be changed nine
times, seven times, or eight
times, but at least seven
times for every hit of the key.
And every time you
push a key, you're
going to get a different
transformation.
So that is the strength
of the Enigma machine.
So I said I wasn't going to
go through the calculation
of the key length of the Enigma.
But I want to
mention what it is.
The Enigma has a
theoretical maximum number
of settings of 3
times 10 to the 114th.
The math is at the back.
You can read it.
But that's far more
than the number
of atoms in the universe.
And for this crowd,
I have to say
it's also 300 trillion
times more than a google.
So it's quite a large number.
Now, the Germans weren't able
to achieve that, actually,
because it would've taken
rooms full of rotors
and other inconveniences.
So the way they used it
with just five rotors,
the way they used the plug board
and so forth, what they saw
was 10 to the 23rd, which
before the days of computers
is nothing to sneeze
at, let me tell you.
10 to the 23rd is still
equivalent to a 7y-bit key,
which if you compare that with
the original DES standard which
was used up until this century,
it's much better than that.
But let's compare it to
what they were expecting.
There were no computers.
They were expecting
brute force, manual type
of breaking of the key.
And to break a key that has 10
to the 23rd as its key length,
it would take 100,000 operators
each checking a different key
every second 24 by 7 for
twice the age of universe
to break this machine.
So I think they felt
pretty safe that this
was a safe machine for them.
And by all rights,
it should have been.
But let's talk about
how the Germans actually
used this Enigma.
First of all, they
had a daily key.
And the daily key, I think
I've already hinted at,
there were five rotors.
They had to select three and
put them in a specific order.
That was the first set of keys.
Then they had to change the
notch setting for two of them.
That is another key.
They had to change the
plug board settings.
Then they had to
place the rotors
in a particular configuration.
Once they set that, they're
able to send a message.
But they didn't just
code in a message.
And the reason is, if you
have hundreds or thousands
of messages all going with the
same key, that could easily
be broken.
Letter frequency analysis
again will tell you
what's the most frequent
letter of the first of each
of these messages, the second
letter in each message,
and so forth.
It would be quickly broken.
So what they had
them do was they
had them send a
new rotor setting.
And they were told
specifically to make it random.
And unfortunately,
what would happen
with the German operators
is they got lazy.
And they would just
use three letters
in a row, or three
columns in a row,
or sometimes their
girlfriend's initials.
In fact, one operator had
a girlfriend named Cil.
And the British called this
type of breaking of code cillies
because it was so frequent.
I mean, he typically
used that every day.
And so we could count on
him to help break codes.
Now, another thing
that they did was they
sent that three-letter
new code twice.
And the reason for
that was they're
sending this by
Morse code, by radio.
And sometimes that
would get garbled.
And they would want
to send it twice
to make sure that it
was received correctly.
So that's what they did.
They would send that twice.
And it turns out that that
slight problem that they
created, or that
slight shortcoming
was exploited by the Polish.
And they were able
to break the code.
So now what I'd like
to do is give you
a demonstration
of this if I can.
I hope you can see enough that
I can explain this to you.
OK.
So like I said, the first
thing you have to do
is set up these rotors
in a particular format.
And so I've set it up.
I've got it written
down here, in fact.
and I will put this in
the message clip holder,
just as the Germans would have.
OK.
So this is my cheat sheet.
So the rotor order is going
to be 3, 1, 2 in my example.
Here's Rotor 1-- I mean 3.
And here's 1, so that's next.
And then 2.
And so that's going
left to right.
That's the order.
You put this on the spindle.
And you kind of
press it together.
And you put it in this-- you
put it in the machine like this.
And it's in there.
Now the other thing we had
to do that I will assume I've
already done this is set the
notches in the right locations.
OK.
Now this is in.
And I can screw this down.
The next thing I have to
do is put these rotors
on a particular setting.
And the setting that
they sent me for today--
and this is a daily setting, so
I have to do this every day--
is EJ zero, EJO.
So I will set this to
EJO, which by the way
all these are in numbers here.
And EJO is 5, 10 and 20.
And if I didn't know that,
there's a little cheat sheet
right here on the lid that
tells me that's 5, 10, and 20.
So it makes it
easy and foolproof.
The next thing I have to
do is set the plug boards.
Now the Germans,
interestingly, always used
10 cables for the plug board.
And you may ask, well,
why don't they use all 13
and swap all the letters?
Well, it turns out 10 is
better than 13 cryptologically.
And in fact, the
cryptologic strength
goes up as you go from
zero cables up to 11.
11 gives the most.
And then it drops
off significantly
when you go to 12 and 13.
So then the question
is, well, why
didn't they use 11 then,
if that was stronger?
Or why didn't they vary
the number of cables?
Here's my theory.
OK.
This is just my own theory.
My own theory is they wanted to
use the same number of cables
so that the cables weren't
laying around extra
and could get lost.
And the other is,
why 10 instead of 11?
They felt 10 was strong enough.
And it kind of matched their
sensibilities of order.
It's a good round
number, you know?
And so why not use 10?
They could send that 10.
It's nice and neat
in their code books.
And that's what they did.
And so that's what they
used, is 10 every time.
So let's assume I've
got that all set up.
And now I'm an operator.
I'm a German operator.
I want to send a message.
So the first thing
I have to do is
I've got it all set up
to the right settings.
And the first thing
I do is I make up
a three-letter new setting.
And being kind of
a bad operator,
I'm going to set it up to
my wife's initials, TES.
So T gives me a
C. Is that right?
Wait a minute.
I've got this-- oh, I'm sorry.
I had this on the wrong thing.
5, 10, and 15.
So I'm going to type
in T. And that gives me
a Y. E, which gives me an H. And
then S. It gives me a Y again.
OK.
Now I have to write
these down, right?
Now, I've got to do
that again, because as I
said I'm typing in TES twice.
So again T. This
time it gives me
a Z. E gives me a C. And
S this time gives me an E.
So those six letters, I have to
write down and send them along
with the message.
But before I encode the message,
I have to set this to the TES,
right?
So T, if I look on my
cheat sheet here, is 20.
E is 5.
And S is 19.
So now I've set my
machine to 20, 5, 19.
That's TES.
And now I can send my message.
And I'm just going to send
a simple hello message.
So I'll type in H. That
gives me an X. E, which
gives me an O. L gives me a D.
I'm typing in L again.
This time I get a Q.
Notice it's different,
because it's a different code.
And then O, which gives me an H.
Now I've got my message to
send, the six letters which
is sending the
new setting twice,
and then the letters of hello.
The way I would send this
is in groups of five.
I would send the message by
Morse code across a radio
usually.
And then the receiver
would get this message.
And the message he
would get would just
be that string of letters
that I just mentioned.
And what he would
do is first set this
to the original
code setting, which
is as I said EJ
zero, 5, 10, and 15.
And he would then decode
the first six letters.
And I don't know if
you were keeping track.
But I have it written
down just in case.
It starts with YHY.
So if I type in Y I get
a T. H gives me an E.
And Y again gives
me an X. That's TES.
That's what I should set it to.
But I'll type in
the next three just
to verify that I didn't
get some garbled message.
And the next three were ZCE.
So I'll type in a
Z. And I get at T.
And I'm sorry.
I'm looking at this
keyboard backwards.
And it's a little bit different.
C is an E. And the
last letter was-- CZE.
And E is an S.
So it verifies.
I got TES again.
So now I know I need to
set my settings to TES.
And when I do that, that's
again I said 20, 5, and 19.
Now I can type in the
rest of the message that
was sent to me.
And that starts with XODQH.
So X gives me an H. O-- oops.
Let me back up a minute.
I didn't see it.
Well, that should
be a-- trust me.
It's an E. It's just not
shining up through this thing
very well.
XOD-- I think it's, let's see.
D. After telling you that this
has worked flawlessly for me,
it seems to be disconnecting.
OK.
There it goes.
Back up.
19.
So it started with X.
That's the H. O. Now
there's something wrong here.
But it worked this morning.
Believe me.
Anyways, you type
in those letters.
And you get H-E-L-L-O. And
that's how you would decipher
the message.
Now this seems
rather convoluted.
In a way, it is.
But comparing this to
previous cipher methods,
this was more foolproof.
It was a much stronger cipher.
And therefore the German
Navy and German Army
definitely relied on this.
They used this extensively.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When they
sent out the daily code,
did they send it encoded
with the previous day's code?
RALPH SIMPSON: No.
No.
The question is, when they
sent out the daily code,
did they send it encoded
with the previous code?
That would be one way to do it.
But what they did was they
sent out a book that had 30
days' worth of
codes written in it.
If you were in the
submarine service, though,
you got three months'
worth of these codes.
And so there again,
keep that in mind,
because that was one of
the shortcomings of this.
And by stealing the code
books, you sometimes
were able to decipher this.
And I think if
they sent it daily,
it might have been a
better way to do it.
AUDIENCE: If you
sent it daily, you
would have been able to decipher
all the codes any time you
had one day's code.
RALPH SIMPSON: Yes.
That's true.
If you ever got one day's code,
yeah, that's the other fallacy,
yeah.
But the books were sent out
widely to all of the Army units
that had these.
And there were tens
of thousands of them.
So that was also dangerous.
And sometimes the Allies
did steal those code books.
Yes.
Can I go back?
AUDIENCE: Was there a
protocol for stolen code
books or [INAUDIBLE]?
RALPH SIMPSON: I don't know if
there was a protocol, because I
think this was something
that they did everything
they could to prevent.
So for instance on a submarine,
if a submarine was lost at sea
or they were sinking, they
were told to blow it up.
Cipher machines, if the
enemy were approaching
and they were
going to lose, they
were ordered to destroy the
cipher machines, the code
books, everything.
The code books for the
boats and the submarines
were made of a water-dissolvable
type of material.
So if it got in the
ocean, it would dissolve.
So there were a lot of
precautions that were taken.
And in fact, I think that
led to some of the reasons
why there are so few Enigma
machines in existence today.
A lot of those were
destroyed by the Nazis
as the Allies advanced
on their positions.
OK.
So that's the demonstration.
I now want to talk about some
of the shortcomings, which
I've already been hinting at.
You see here a picture of
Panzer General Heinz Guderian.
And in the bottom left,
you'll see an Enigma machine.
And it's interesting that
there's an Enigma operator
there.
And beside him is the
person that would typically
be telling him the message to
decipher and writing it down.
And then the third person is the
person that operates the radio
and sends the Morse
code back and forth.
So this is quite an
elaborate operation.
There's three operators
there to send a message.
And in fact, I
would say that one
of the shortcomings of this
machine is that it's so strong.
And so let me elaborate.
The cryptologic strength
of this was so good
that the Germans never
believed that it was broken,
all throughout the war
and afterwards, even when
they were presented with
pretty strong evidence
that it was broken
and they were told
it was broken by their
allies, the Japanese.
They didn't believe it.
They didn't believe
that it could be broken.
So that was one of
the shortcomings.
Another is this
reflector design.
I mentioned that it
allows for ease of use
by deciphering and
enciphering with the same key.
But what it also
did was it made sure
that no letter got
encoded to itself.
And one of the ways that the
Allies liked to break codes
is come up with a crib.
And a crib is what they think
could be included in a message.
And the Germans being very
precise in their language
and especially in
the military, we
could count on them to use
certain words over and over
in messages.
And one of them was
a weather report
that went out to the minute
every day in the morning.
And the front of it
said weather report.
And by using those words,
you can pretty well tell.
You can eliminate a
lot of rotor positions,
because you can't have
one letter coming back
to the same letter.
So it wouldn't necessarily
tell you the code.
But it would tell you
which ones to eliminate.
So you don't have the 10 to the
23rd key settings to try out.
The other is that the rotors
had a regular odometer
motion to them.
Now, it turns out that the US,
besides these 140,000 machines
which were used in
the battlefield,
had another machine
that was more
similar to this called a SIGABA.
And the difference between
the SIGABA and this
is that it had 10 rotors
to change the letters.
And it had five other
rotors to change
the motion of those 10 rotors.
And it was irregular.
And so by having an
irregular motion,
you've just added immensely
to the cryptologic strength.
And in fact, that machine was
never broken by the Germans.
But anyways, the
odometer movement
is a problem because
what that means
is you're only changing
one rotor for 26 times.
And then when this one flips,
you go in another 26 times only
changing that same
fast-moving rotor.
And so the third rotor
actually never moves
in the entire message.
And the reason is that the
Germans were told never
to send a message more
than 250 characters.
When you do, you go all over
again and send a new setting.
And 250 wouldn't allow
that third rotor to move.
So that was one of the problems.
And another is
the lax operations
by some of the
operators, especially
in the Army and the
Air Force, for instance
using girlfriend's initials
and things like that.
Sometimes they
even went so far as
to send a message twice
with different keys,
like they accidentally didn't
reset the keys from yesterday
and then they sent the same
message with today's key.
That's a huge, huge
problem for anybody
that understands
cryptography that you
can break into a code that way.
So let me ask you, see that
Enigma machine in the corner?
I've blown it up here.
Is there anything
unusual that you
can tell about that
Enigma machine?
Can anybody spot it?
It's not real obvious.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RALPH SIMPSON: What's that?
RALPH SIMPSON: Yes.
Exactly.
It's missing a plug board.
So, if you look at
this machine, it's
actually not missing
the plug board.
They put some white paper
or cardboard or something
over the plug board.
Now this was a picture
taken at World War II.
Why would they cover over
the plug board, you may ask.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RALPH SIMPSON: What's that?
RALPH SIMPSON: Yeah.
Those changed every day.
They changed every day.
So it's not a matter of
giving away a secret,
or not a secret
of the plug board.
But I have another
picture of a plug board.
And you can see that
also has that covered.
I went back and looked at a lot
of different Enigma pictures
from World War II that
came from the Germans.
And they all are
either covered over
or they show it at an angle that
you can't see the plug board.
And I think it's because
this was a military edition.
They felt it was
a secret edition.
And all the other
Enigma machines
went out without a plug board.
In fact, they also sold
these Enigma machines
to the Italians and the
Japanese sans the plug board.
Yes?
Question?
AUDIENCE: You sure it
wasn't just a wrist strap?
RALPH SIMPSON: The
question is, am I sure
it's not a wrist strap.
Well, if you put this
up, it doesn't really
provide much of a
wrist rest there,
because you've got the
wooden board here anyways.
And on top of that,
you're not touch-typing.
You have to push down
pretty hard on these things.
So I though that
was interesting,
that they felt that this plug
board was important enough
that they kept it
covered in the pictures.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So a machine
without a plug board
would not be able
to decode a message
from a machine
with a plug board?
RALPH SIMPSON: That's right.
Exactly.
So the question is, if it didn't
have a plug board you couldn't
decode a message from a
machine with a plug board.
And that's true, because that
adds a whole different levels.
Unless you took
out all the plugs.
Then it would be equivalent.
OK.
So let's talk about
how the Allies actually
broke the Enigma code.
It was broken by the Polish.
And I'm sure all of you
have heard the story.
This seemed to be a little
bit kept secret, not secret,
but people thought
that the British
are the ones that broke it.
But actually the Polish did.
And what happened was, in
1932, being between Germany
and Russia, they
were very nervous
about the military buildup
of these large countries
on their borders.
And so they were carefully
looking at the messages
that the Germans were sending.
And they noticed a
difference in 1932.
And that difference was it
looked like these were not
being coded with the same cipher
machines that they were using,
or the cipher devices they
were using in the past.
And it was some kind
of machine cipher.
They eventually were able to
reverse-engineer an Enigma
machine.
They figured that out
through the commercial Enigma
and saw that they also had
some kind of other swap,
like the plug board.
And so they
reverse-engineered it.
And also the Polish
did something else.
For the first time
in a cipher bureau,
they hired mathematicians.
And Marian Rejewski was
the main mathematician
that they hired who ended
up breaking the code.
And it turns out
that they actually
could not break the
code even with this.
First of all, they
only had three people
working on this in Poland.
OK.
Three mathematicians.
But in 1933, it turns out
that the French approached
an official in the cipher
bureau by the name of Hans-Thilo
Schmidt.
He got that position
because he's
the brother of a
decorated Panzer general.
But this particular
person was in debt.
He needed money.
He spent a lot of money
on wine, women, and song.
And as they say,
he wasted the rest.
Since he was in need of
money, he went to the French
and offered the Enigma
codes, the keys,
and some diagrams of the Enigma.
And so the French took
it, gave it to the Poles
and to the English.
And the French and English
could not break the code even
with those keys.
Now, they could break
the codes for those days,
but it didn't help them
break it afterward.
The Poles took that
information, got
the information about the
double-coding of the day's
keys, the three-letter setting.
They were able to figure
out that if you typed
TES twice, the T and the T, if
the second rotor hasn't moved
gives you a hint,
and the E and the E
and the S and S. You don't
know what letters they are,
but you know that
they're the same.
And so that gives
you a hint, if you
had the rotor wiring
and the reflector wiring
to help figure this out.
And they were able
to figure it out.
It's maybe not quite as
simple as I described.
It still took quite a while.
But they were able to figure
that out in 1933, early '33.
They had broken the code and
were reading it until 1939
when they got invaded.
And the day they got
invaded, September 1, '39,
is the first day
of World War II.
So they were successful in this.
It turns out that
in July of '39,
they finally told their allies,
the French, who had given them
the way to break
it, and the English.
And both the French
and English were
astonished that
they'd been breaking
this code for 6 and 1/2 years
and they had not themselves
made any progress.
And in fact,
besides breaking it,
the Poles made what
they called a bombe.
It was a device that strung
together six Enigma machines
and allowed them to break
the code much faster.
They were able to break
the code typically
in about 15 minutes every day.
And then the rest
of the day, they
would decode them in
real time, just as fast
as the Germans
were decoding them.
And so this was
quite a breakthrough.
They passed this along.
And unfortunately
for them, they passed
along replica machines, all
the information they had.
And then very quickly afterwards
the Germans invaded Poland.
And it was all over for them.
And so the UK set
up a major operation
to help break this code.
Here's their park.
They bought this home
in Bletchley Park,
north of London.
They had up to 11,000
people working on this.
Remember, the Poles had three.
But to their credit, they had a
much tougher problem to solve.
When the Poles had to
solve this problem,
there were only three rotors.
And so the three rotors
were in different positions,
of which there's only six.
That's why their
six-machine bombe worked.
But now that there's
five rotors to pick from,
now all of a sudden you need 60.
They didn't have the ability to
create a bombe with 60 rotors.
And so they left
it to the English.
Now, the English also could
have done a 60 rotor bombe.
But that would have been
quite an undertaking.
They figured out they
could do a 36-Engima bombe
and manually eliminate
some of the settings
and still figure out
the code fast enough.
So that's what they did.
They made a 36-machine bombe.
And they were able to break the
code, typically in a few hours,
because what it would do is
it would allow the operator
to know which
settings could work.
Then they'd have
to manually test
that setting and then go
on and test the next one.
Also interestingly,
throughout the war
the British were very careful
with this information.
So if they got information
that said, for instance,
that a submarine was going to
surface at a certain location
to be resupplied
by a mother ship,
they wouldn't just go and bomb
that location, because then it
would give away that they
had read this message.
So what they would do is
they would fly a spotter
plane over it, make
sure the German saw it.
Then their boat that
happened to be nearby
would come over and
bomb it and blow it up.
This almost backfired
on them once.
They knew that there were going
to be two submarines being
resupplied in this remote
location in the Atlantic.
So they sent out
this spotter plane.
They bombed it.
But in that same
exact message it
said that there were going to
be these other submarines going
through this strait
in northern Europe.
And they had to decide which
ones they wanted to bomb.
They decided to get the
ones in the mid-Atlantic.
Well, it turns out that
legitimately the Allies
found these submarines
going through this strait.
And they knocked
one of them out.
And so this caused a big
concern by the British military.
And in fact, Hitler
called a meeting
that included the Navy, the
Air Force, and the Army.
And all of the heads
of these groups
came in to discuss
the possibility
that the Allies had
broken the code.
But they also
brought in the person
that was in charge of
the Enigma machine,
who told them why it was
absolutely impossible for them
to have broken this code.
And so they all went
on their merry way.
And nothing was done.
They could have easily
started changing things.
But they didn't even do that.
So let me set what was going
on in the North Atlantic
with the U-boats.
Before the US entered
the war, the U-boats
were having a field day.
They were sinking
Allied boats in droves.
In the few months before
the US entered the war,
it was 60 boats per month,
at a tremendous loss
of life and loss of
supplies that were really
needed for the war
effort for the Allies.
The U-boats, the way they
would do this is they
would form wolf packs.
There would be a
number of U-boats
all roaming around the Atlantic.
They would spot a convoy,
because they were all
separated.
But rather than attack
it with one U-boat,
they would send a message
back to headquarters.
Headquarters would then
say, form a wolf pack.
Here's the location.
Maybe up to a dozen
U-boats would go there.
And they'd all pick
out a different boat.
And they'd fire on
them simultaneously.
And it was at a tremendous
loss of life for the Allies.
And this went on
for many months.
So it turns out that this was
a major strategy of Hitler's.
He was expecting that the UK
would capitulate and surrender
because of this, because of this
blockade and lack of supplies.
And you can see the quote
here from Winston Churchill.
He said the only thing that
ever really frightened me
during the war was
the U-boat peril.
Now this is despite the V-2
peril, the peril of D-Day
and the landing there, all the
problems they had in Africa.
The U-boat peril was the only
thing that really frightened
him, and I think
for good reason.
I mean, this could have
lost the war for him.
So here's what changed that.
U-110.
You've probably heard about
the movie or seen the movie
"U-571."
That was an important
U-boat that was captured,
code keys and all that.
But this was the
first one, the U-110.
And here you see the captain.
He was actually a hero in this.
The U-boat was purposely
captured in a way
that they wanted to get the
code keys from the U-boat.
And so when it was bombed and it
surfaced, rather than just let
everybody surrender,
if they did,
they would have
scuttled the U-boat.
They would have set
off charges within it
and it would have sank.
So they purposely started
shooting at the tower
to get everybody out of the
boat quickly before they
could set these depth charges.
And they did.
And by getting
everybody out quickly,
they then rounded
them up and put them
on the Allies' boat,
this "HMS Bulldog."
And the captain saw
what was happening.
And he saw that the
charges were not set.
So he jumped in the
water to swim back
to set the charges
to sink his boat.
And the Allies saw
that and killed him.
And so the Allies went on board,
got all the Enigma machines,
all the code books.
And this boat happened to have
been out for about one month.
As I said, they have three
months' worth of code settings.
So the Allies now had the next
two months' of code settings
that they could
break very easily.
And that's exactly
what they did.
This single act is what changed
the Battle of the Atlantic.
And the reason was, not only
did they have the next two
months', it gave them insights
into the kinds of messages
the Germans were sending, the
kinds of cribs they could look
for, and how they could then
break future Enigma codes from
the Navy.
So here's how this goes back
to the beginning of computing.
And the father of computing
is considered Alan Turing.
[SOUNDS FROM LOUDSPEAKER]
RALPH SIMPSON: Hello?
OK.
So here's Alan Turing.
He was the person that
led the effort in the UK
in breaking the code.
He was a mathematician,
who came up
with-- he was the brains
behind breaking the code.
And he came up with the
English version of the bombe.
By the way the bombe
was named after they
think an ice cream treat that
the Polish code breakers were
eating at the time they
came up with the idea.
But others say it could
be the ticking of a bomb.
So we're not really sure.
In the UK, they built
210 of these things.
Now these, as you can see,
they're not insignificant.
They're quite large.
The one you're looking at here
is the US version of the bome.
The English version had a
column of three Enigma rotors.
And it simulated 36 machines.
These rotors on
the English version
would spin about twice a second,
so quite fast, but slow enough
that when they got a possible
hit it could just stop.
The operator would then write
down that setting for someone
to manually test
out to see if that
could be a possible setting.
Meanwhile, they would
start back the machine
and it would spin again.
Now, all of that would not have
worked for the Naval Enigma.
And the reason is
there's just not
enough hours in
the day to do this.
The Naval Enigma, having four
rotors selected from eight,
it's hugely more
difficult to break.
They also had a
selection of reflectors
that I didn't mention
that were pluggable,
so they could change
the reflector.
So it was immensely
more complex.
And so what the US did was they
invented a new kind of bombe.
Not only did it have four
rotors and it spun faster--
it spun at a rate of 29
revolutions per second.
So the problem with that is--
well, first of all, the problem
is the brushes wore out quickly
and it was tough to manage.
But the other problem
was you couldn't stop it
and then read the setting.
It was spinning
too fast to stop it
on a dime like that when it's
going 29 times per second.
So what they did was they
came up with a new invention.
And that invention is
memory, believe it or not.
So the top of that
machine, that box
that you see on top,
that long box, that
is memory for four
bytes of information.
[LAUGHTER]
And you can see this
machine at the NSA cipher
museum in Maryland.
That top box held radio tubes.
Each radio tube represented
a bit of information.
And it held the four bytes
that represented the code here
of the rotor code.
And it would print it out.
So this was a major advance.
And I would almost say this
is-- it's memory, right?
So it's the beginning
of modern computing.
The British also came
up with another machine
to break a different type
of cipher device, which
was the cipher device
they used for telegraphs.
And that was called Colossus.
And that also was another step
forward in modern computing,
because it was programmable.
So this is the
beginning of computing.
This is what we're
talking about here
as far as this homely
little wooden box that
looks like a typewriter set the
stage for things like computing
and Silicon Valley and
Google and all of that.
So by the end of
the war, the US was
able to break the Naval
Enigma code in 12 hours.
That's quite a while.
But from then on, they
were broken in real time.
So that was quite an
advantage that they had.
They were able to identify
where these submarines were.They
were able to blast
them out of the water.
And it turned the tide.
This turned the tide of
the Battle of the Atlantic.
It was unfortunate that by
finding out where they were,
they had to select which
convoys they were going to save.
They could not save them all.
That would just give
away the entire secret.
And then they would be
out, that information.
So they would have
to selectively pick
which ones they wanted
to take care of.
Another way that they were able
to break these code that they
found out was that
the weather trawlers,
these were almost
unarmed small boats
that they could easily capture.
And they would have three
months' worth of Enigma codes
on them.
And they would
purposely, of course,
sink them immediately and make
sure that the Germans never
suspected that they
were really after them
to get the code books.
So what happened by
the end of the war
was that 82% of the sailors that
went into service-- including
the Admiral's son, Admiral
Donitz who was in charge of all
these, his son was one
of them-- died at sea.
And 725 of 1,155
U-boats were gone.
And in fact, toward
the end of the war,
even before the end
of the war, they
quit going out into the
Atlantic altogether.
It just was not
fruitful for them.
They were losing more submarines
than they were sinking boats.
One of the things
that you'll read
if you read up on the
Enigma, a lot of people
will claim that
breaking the Enigma
allowed the Allies to shorten
the war by about two years.
That's a made-up number.
I don't know if it's true.
But two years would
definitely have
saved millions and
millions of lives.
I think there is no
doubt that whether it's
two years, three
years, one year,
it made a change and a
huge difference in the war.
But even I think
greater than that
was breaking it
allowed the invention
of the modern computing, which
has changed our lives forever.
And I think that is the
legacy of this device.
Now, after World War II,
it's also interesting
that a couple things happened.
One was nothing happened.
So here we have
this huge success.
There were 11,000 people
working on breaking
this code in the UK.
And there were several
thousand in the US.
And nobody told this secret.
I can't imagine this happening
today in a day of Snowden
and releases and all
that kind of stuff.
But this was kept secret
for 30 years, until 1974.
So in the meantime, there were
some of these Enigma machines
around, some of them
without the plug boards.
And the US and the UK encouraged
our allies to use these things.
And our allies and enemies
alike used them for 30 years.
And unbeknownst to them,
they were being cracked.
And this particular machine came
from Norway, one of our allies.
They were invaded early
on in World War II.
The Germans left
behind these machines,
because when they left,
they didn't have time
to destroy all the things
they left behind in Norway.
So Norway's secret police,
their equivalent of the CIA,
used these machines
for 30 years,
with the US and Britain decoding
every one of those messages.
So in 1974, when
this was disclosed,
they made these things surplus.
And as a result, it went
on the surplus market
and eventually into my hands.
The other thing I should
mention is kind of a rarity.
Some people ask me, how
many of these were made?
How much are they worth?
Those kind of things.
We think about 30,000 of these
machines with the plug boards
were made.
We found serial numbers
up into 28,000's, so we're
assuming around
30,000 were made.
Today, we know of
about 350 that exist.
Half of those are in museums.
Half are in private hands.
And of those half that are
in private hands, about half
of them are in the US.
So the US has half of them.
The rest are scattered
around the rest of the world.
And these things have
been quite collectible.
Around the year 2000, you
could pick these things up
for $20,000 or less.
And they stayed that way
for quite a few years.
I picked this up in 2002
for less than $20,000.
But today, they seem to be
going for over $200,000.
The highest that I know of
one selling for was $260,000.
But oftentimes they're going
on Sotheby's or Christie's
or something like that and
they're bringing $200,000,
I think partially because of
the added notoriety because
of a couple of movies
that have come out.
One was called "Enigma."
One was called "U-571," which
depicts a US crew boarding
a submarine and
stealing the codes.
It's actually a British
crew that did this,
so the British aren't
too happy with our movie.
But that's what's happened.
And I call this a collector's
item for the uber-geek.
So I consider
myself an uber-geek
for having such a thing.
If you're interested in
downloading this presentation,
I have it on my website.
My website is
ciphermachines.com.
You can just type
that in Enigma.ppt,
and you can download this
entire presentation, including
the follow-on addendum that has
the mathematical calculation
for the key, for the
length of the key.
So are there any
other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the actual
origin of the word Enigma?
RALPH SIMPSON: I don't know the
actual-- some people have asked
me, because they think did the
US or the British use this word
and the Germans did not.
It turns out enigma means
the same thing in German
as it does in English.
And it's spelled the same way.
Now, I don't know if
that's part of the reason
that Scherbius picked that name.
But enigma means the same thing.
It's a puzzle, a tough puzzle
to break or something like that.
And it's identical
in both languages
and spelled the same way.
So maybe that's just fortunate.
I don't know.
But I'm not sure of the
original origin of the name.
Yes?
Other questions?
Comments?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
published the way that works.
And other people have
designed replicas [INAUDIBLE]?
RALPH SIMPSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Has anybody actually
published engineering diagrams
of the actual mechanics
of the machine?
RALPH SIMPSON: So the
question is, has anybody
published engineering
diagrams of the mechanics
of the machine?
I believe they have.
Now, I haven't really looked for
that, so I can't say for sure.
But I believe they have.
I think that-- if
you look online,
I think you'll find quite a bit.
I know of a person in North
Carolina who actually makes
these replicas to be almost
as precise as could be,
other than they look new.
So when he builds it, you
can't tell the difference other
than it looks new.
And he uses the
same crinkle paint,
the same exact materials.
And I believe he goes
to Germany to get
the same trees to make the wood.
So it's quite precise.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RALPH SIMPSON: Yes.
And actually, one of
things that surprised me
when I received this
machine was it's
in relatively good condition.
If you take a look--
afterwards you're
welcome to come up and take a
look-- the paint looks good.
It's hard to believe
that it was made in 1941.
It's over 70 years old.
It went through the
war and afterwards.
And it still looks in
relatively good condition.
I think that these were pretty
well babied by their operators.
I think they understood
the value of it.
They knew that they were to
value this with their life,
that if an enemy came along,
they were to destroy it.
And therefore, they took
very good care of them.
Although, on the
outside the box,
you can see that there
is quite a bit of-- I've
got something blocking it here.
There's some scratches
and so forth.
But for a 70-year-old
device, I would
say that's in
relatively good shape
for going through the war.
I can imagine this thing
got quite a bit of use
during that time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RALPH SIMPSON: OK.
The question is, why did the
Navy switch to a better one
and the Army and
Air Force didn't?
I think it has to do--
and this is my theory.
I think it has to do
with Admiral Donitz.
He was skeptical
that this had not
been broken, because
he was not-- I mean,
he trusted his submarine
operators and commanders
to be able to do what was
needed to fight the war.
And they were losing.
And there were enough
evidence that he
thought that this
could be broken.
On the other hand, it
could've been spies.
You know, it could have been
other technologies, like radio
direction finders or
something like that.
But I think he was
suspicious all along.
And so part of the
way along the way
he came up and had them
design the four-rotor.
The Army and Navy
decided they didn't
want to go with that, because
it would have been quite a bit
more work for them to them
swap out all these machines.
And remember, there could've
been 30,000 of these.
To swap those out in
that many locations
versus a few submarines
and a few boats,
it was easier for
the Navy to do that.
I think it was a combination
of things like that.
In fact, they interviewed
Admiral Donitz after the war
and asked him if he thought
that the code was broken.
And he said no way.
And then in '74 when it was
announced that it was, just
before his death, he
was quite surprised.
So I think even though
he was suspicious,
he still believed
that it was safe.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So how
much more complex
would it have to be for it
to be-- for them to have not
been able to take 12 hours,
say 36 hours for them
to break the code?
RALPH SIMPSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How much
more complicated
would they have had to make
it so that [INAUDIBLE]?
RALPH SIMPSON: OK.
So the question is,
how much more complex
would the device
have to be that it
couldn't be broken in 12 hours?
And just adding-- not
even adding another rotor
to the design, but adding a
couple more rotors to what
can be selected from would
probably do that and more.
That adds a lot
of complexity when
you have these extra rotors.
And if you only supplying
a few to some boats
and some submarines, you
can probably do that.
I don't think they
felt it was necessary.
And so why didn't they do it?
They had no suspicion that
this was broken, because
of the care that was
taken to make sure
that they didn't
misuse the information.
The British didn't even
tell their commanders
many times where
this was coming from.
They would tell them this
came from a trusted spy.
And so they would act
on the information,
but not even know that it came
from breaking the Enigma code.
Yes?
I think we're out of time?
OK.
We're out of time.
Feel free to come and take
a look at the machine.
I thank you very much for
your time and attention.
[APPLAUSE]